[Music]
the couple leaving right now is Terrell
and Cheryl what's your big takeaway from
this experience makers you always dive
in headfirst and everything um just just
the building of relationships and the
new friendship that I've been able to
gain and just again like I said just to
start out you know not having any
experience and really just riding along
with the with the wave and I think I
couldn't have asked for a better partner
again it was it wasn't easy it was
frustrating at times it was it was
grueling but at the same time I had a
lot of fun you know with the process
okay if we get three turns don't go out
on a date with that being said we gotta
go get some practice in because I want
to get that team you got a little bit of
spare time on your hands how about a
date with a young Kelly Monaco all right
you know she said I asked her and she
said she was gonna DM me translate she
goes damn me where you gonna take her if
you had a youth get a chance for you it
was the worst date and I could have I'll
be right there
oh yeah I'll be like yes no no yes you
know watch those hands too
you